as Russia's cruelty deepens
the resolve of this contact group grows
and that's clear from the announcements
that we've heard today and I'll start
with air defense
several countries have come forward with
key donations that will help protect
Ukraine skies and cities and citizens
in France Germany and the UK have all
donated air defense systems to Ukraine
and that includes a patriot battery from
Germany
and that's especially important coming
alongside our own contribution of a
patriot system
and the Netherlands is also donating
Patriot missiles and launchers and
training
meanwhile Canada has procured a nasam
system
in Associated Munitions for Ukraine
and so these air defense systems will
help save countless innocent lives
we're also pushing hard to meet
Ukraine's requirements for tanks and
other armored vehicles
the UK has announced a significant
donation of Challenger 2 tanks for
Ukraine
this is the first introduction of
Western Maine battle tanks into Ukraine
may also commend our British allies for
for making this decision
and Sweden announced it's donating cd-90
infantry fighting vehicles
and an additional donation soon of
Archer howitzers
you've also heard inspiring and
important new donation announcements
from several other countries and and
that includes Denmark which will donate
19 howritters
and Latvia is donating more stingers and
helicopters and other equipment
and Estonia is providing Ukraine with a
significant new package of much needed
155 millimeter howitzers and munitions
now all of today's announcements
are are direct results of our work at
the contact group
and these important new commitments
demonstrate the ongoing resolve of our
allies and partners to help Ukraine
defend itself
because this isn't just about Ukraine's
security
it's also about European security
and it's about Global Security
it's about the kind of world that we
want to live in
and it's about the world that we want
our children and grandchildren to
inherit
the members of this contact group are
standing up
for a world where where rules matter
and we're rights matter
and where sovereignty is respected
and where people can choose their own
path
free from tyranny and aggression
and I'm confident that this group
will remain United
and we'll continue to build momentum
we'll support Ukraine against Russian
aggression for the Long Haul
and we'll continue to work toward a free
and security right Ukraine in a stable
and decent world